hey let's start for lauer came back on
june 1st it wasn't very good only two
innings seven runs but his last timeout
out of the bullpen against these reds
four innings two runs bases loaded had a
chance to do damage joey votto has
knocked in a run in five consecutive
games 3-1
hard hit
nice pick by vogelback
he hits the bag winker scores
castellanos over to third stevenson
takes second reds are on the board joey
votto has an rbi in six consecutive
games tying the longest run of his
career hey eugenio suarez has been
coming on homeward yesterday 3-2
struck him out high fastball and somehow
lauer houdini's his way through that top
of the first gives up a run brewer's
coming up and vladimir gutierrez back on
the hill john sadek his numbers from
western and southern thank you jim three
starts for gutierrez 17 innings and
there's one away here's daniel vogelback
and the 2-1 delivery a swing and a drive
to right and deep get up
get up get
and this one is tied he hit one to the
second deck in right above the reds
bullpen daniel vogelback with number
seven on the year ties the game at one a
piece the second inning begins walk
single but here's the pitcher gutierrez
corners crash
pull go back
skip in the dirt there for the force to
cut down aquino
even a guy who's not known for his
defense if he's playing as that close to
home plate
and you bunt it to him he's going to get
the lead runner i mean the only thing
the pitcher has to do is butt it down
the third base line if he's able to do
that but if you notice the way the
gutierrez set up at home plate
to lay the bun down he never did angle
his bat to be able to bunt it anywhere
but either to the pitcher or the first
base jonathan india 0-1
india cranks that one into the gap skips
all the way to the wall farmer scores
stop sign gutierrez reds take the lead a
standing rbi doubled by jonathan india
two one reds amended second and third
for jesse winker and winker
drops that one into center field
gutierrez scores
a single for winker and the reds a 3-1
lead in the second inning first and
third for castiano's broken bat bouncer
to second peterson beams adamus not in
time india scores four one reds well
after you get jammed like this like
castiano's does the only thing you can
do is be mad and run it as hard as you
can to first base so eric lauer at the
plate he has hit a home run this year
aquino's gonna have a play on it it's
gonna be deep enough to score peterson
to sac fly for eric lauer to bring the
brewers to run closer there you go
that's a pretty good hack right there on
the pitch
three and one got the trash ball rbi for
eric lower power hoping to back up what
he did in the third
ground ball to a domiciled short low
throw dug out by vogelback and farmers
out number one single and a double here
tonight for jonathan india india to
second base it's a quick and easy inning
for
eric lauer minimal pitches three up
three down one and two on adamus
swing and a miss
and you could see that kurt nod in
agreement
with his catcher tyler stevenson there
is something
rhythmic and almost veteran about this
rookie well look how he just really
pushed off and followed through finished
this pitch got it to a spot that he
wanted which is up and away we've kind
of seen this from gutierrez he seems to
get a little bit better after a couple
of innings they want to be challenged
four straight breaking balls
winker tracks that down
two up two down it's six in a row
retired by gutierrez
two strikeouts today for gutierrez
bradley having a trying year
swinging a miss
challenges him on a fastball but seven
straight retired now by vladimir
gutierrez he's fanned three in this one
we go to the fifth the one-two pitch
check swing at the bolt in the dirt
he went oh wow
oh the crowd groans
the appeals strike and that's a big
strikeout for gutierrez but again the
rule
is did the batter offer to hit the pitch
it's not whether he crossed the plane of
the plate or whether he broke his wrists
or where the bat head is although the
first base umpire normally looks at that
bat head and that's how he determines
adamus hit the ball fairly well
to center field in the second inning
swing into this struck him out
two k's on the inning and vladimir
gutierrez retires 13 of his last 14.
the rookie has been a rock
4-2
bottle with rbi ground out
golfs that shot to right field a twisted
garcia watches and it rattles in the
first roll for a homer
two-run bomb by joey votto with
breathing room for the reds it's six to
two
now the one thing standing up tall
in the batter's box does is it allows
you to drop the bat head
and i think this is part of what joey
vado wanted to do and you become more of
the traditional left-hander with a low
wheel house
plenty strong enough
and gets it you're right golfed it right
on out of here
vano just went down there with a three
iron and hit it out of here aquino but
he had not played for the reds since
april 13th in san francisco
shallow pop-up jackie bradley jr sliding
and he took it off the turf for the
final out of the inning first step was
back he's got the speed to gain so much
ground nice sliding catch jackie bradley
jr suarez is hit safely in three
straight but
has been held hitless tonight
shallow center
drops on down
stevenson scores votto given the green
light two-run blooper by a eugeo suarez
8-2
ribs that's where you know i don't know
if the reds need that eighth run or not
but that's where that base running by
joey votto
missing the cut-off man allowing bottle
to go to second base you pick up another
run you pick up another run batted end
if you're suarez kino ahead two balls in
a strike left-handed pitcher
right-handed batter aquino cranks it to
left hit a ton way back goodbye
into the second deck and left the
punisher returns
a two-run shot a four-run ninth inning
for the reds ten two red legs
two away
pablo reyes will pinch it for willie
adamus here's the 1-1
hey swings lifts one high in the air
center field aquino moves under it
waiting on it he's got it that's it reds
win it 10-2 over the brewers the reds
have won their fourth straight